let's see I got one more
story this is from the daily wire
airport workers backed by one of the
biggest labor unions in the nation
protested at LAX airport this week for
stricter Airline emission regulations to
combat environmental racism the
protesters are members of the service
employees International Union United
service workers West organization and
the airports Workers United the protests
occurred in front of a departure
terminal at the airport protesters used
the phrase no justice no peace and no
clean air no peace I think we have
footage of this aspiring protest let's
watch it
[Applause]
what's up
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
okay so that was the protest outside the
airport and and by the way I was just
looking uh so they're they're protesting
environmental racism and uh the article
says
what is that environmental race is a
disproportionate impact of environmental
hazards of people of color uh
communities of color are more likely to
live in polluted neighborhoods and as a
result we suffer the highest rates of
asthma cancer and heart disease
so that's what environmental racism is
so first of all just to say that there
is no sure way to persuade people to
hate you and your cause than to Stage a
protest at an airport LAX of all
airports I mean LAX is already the worst
airport in the history of Aviation the
oh is the I mean honestly the only good
thing about LAX and I think about this
every time I'm on my way to LAX only
good thing is one bright side which is
that if your plane crashes on the way to
that airport then it does give you
like a silver lining to think about as
you plunge to your death you could just
think to yourself well at least I don't
have to deal with lax now that's the
only good thing about it LAX is so bad
that the last time I was there uh our
our plane had had landed and pulled up
to the gate
and it still took us an hour okay an
hour
to get off the plane even from the time
we pulled into the gate it took us an
hour to get off the plane because they
couldn't find any gate agents to come
and operate the Jet Bridge thing and
open the door they couldn't find anyone
to open the door so we waited an hour
for someone to open the door and you
know the flight attendants are like
calling in and saying can someone come
and open the door and people it's like
so workers are on their lunch break and
yeah you guys could wait
uh it it LAX is an airport it's run and
staffed by people who who've never been
inside an airport before that's what it
feels like like all their employees at
LAX airport
emerge from some sort of time portal
from the year 1760. they just walk
around looking baffled utterly perplexed
if you if you need them for anything if
you had to ask them to do anything they
just they're completely confused
I mean it's really every airport in the
country but especially LAX so now
imagine that things are even more
congested and even slower than usual
because there are environmentalist
hippies staging a protest out front
my God and now imagine that you're
you're sitting in traffic on your way to
the airport and traffic is heavy because
their environmental is blocking the road
for a protest and then once you get
there there are even more
environmentalists at the airport uh
clogging things up
these people are
I I mean we I've never seen a a
political movement quite like this where
the the people involved in the movement
are utterly determined to make us hate
them
and and mission accomplished by the way
but at least we now know what
environmental racism is environmental
racism apparently is not as I had
assumed you know maybe as you was
assumed from the from that term you
think environmental racism that must be
when when the environment itself is
racist like the climate has been
radicalized by Fox News or something
that's not what it is environmental
racism is the claim that racial
minorities are somehow more impacted by
the environment than the rest of us
I mean the environment is the thing that
we all live in so you know you think if
there was anything like the left they
always like to take their special victim
groups and say this really impacts these
people the most you think if there was
one thing they couldn't do that with
it's the climate and the environment
because we all live on earth and we are
all subject to it really to the same
degree
uh but even this they do that with
because they say that uh minorities are
more likely to live in urban areas and
and uh and it's polluted and all the
rest of it which which you know that
part is true
but you know here's the great thing
if you live in in a you know urban area
and there's a lot of pollution and it's
gross and there's litter and there's
it's just disgusting and you're just
surrounded by by I mean ironically
you're not really surrounded by the
natural environment at all you're
surrounded by concrete and glass and
plastic and everything and you're
getting asthma uh and and all the rest
of it if you find yourself in that
situation
and you don't want to be in that
situation which I understand I wouldn't
want to live that that way either then
here's what you can do you can move
just move to a different place don't
don't live there anymore
just a a radical idea just a suggestion
I wanted to throw out there thanks for
checking out this video if you'd like to
listen to my full podcast on the go you
can check out the Matt Walsh show on
Apple podcast Spotify or wherever you
get your podcasts